hello Yale my name is Andy McGraw I'm a
music professor here at the University
of Richmond coming to you from our
gamelan studio I wanted to set up the
following video performance for you a
bit this is a traditional balinese YN
cool it or shadow theatre performed by
gusta puto Siddhartha from the
Indonesian Institute of the Arts who is
in residence with us in Richmond up
until this week is a shortened
performance a little over an hour in
Bali traditional Wyong lasts about three
and a half hours the first 15 minutes of
our performance is an instrumental
overture so it takes a while before the
story proper starts in Balinese
performances this overture could be
about 40 minutes long I encourage you to
take that time to read through the
supplemental reading I've prepared and
linked in the YouTube description this
includes an excerpt from Lisa Gold's
music and Bali BIOS of the performers
and an outline of the narrative that
gusta used for this performance at about
15 minutes in when goose T begins
singing I encourage you to follow along
with the transcript and translation of
the narrative provided in the supplement
traditional balinese Wong are presented
in a combination of languages including
Cowie which is an ancient liturgical
Balinese modern Balinese and often some
bahasa indonesia this performance is
presented in Cowie Balinese and English
but goose T's accent is a little thick
so reading along would probably be
helpful
goose T is accompanied by members of
gamelan raga kusuma
our community gamelan here in Richmond
founded in 2008 by goose T and myself
but I encourage you to seek out videos
on YouTube of professional Balinese
musicians accompanying lion a good place
to start would be to YouTube
performances by the da Lang YN we Jia W
IJ a finally we want to thank yell and
the Council on Southeast Asian Studies
for agreeing to fund this performance
considering the extraordinary
circumstances we all know that watching
a video just
isn't the same as having the opportunity
to experience it live and ask questions
of the performers afterward but the
funds we are able to provide for goose t
through these are even more important
now if we think that the pandemic is
going to be bad in the u.s. it's going
to be worse in Indonesia given their
health care system and these performance
funds will help him whether inevitable
changes thank you enjoy the show and
feel free to reach out to me at a mcgraw
at Richmond edu AMC GRA W at Richmond
dot edu if you have any questions thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know we don't but you who know me go
on you
[Music]
Allianz beyond terrified lot Samara
soccer new super random in karate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listen to some it annona muricata Lou
wear neon hula Matano cologne a doctor
up one under capital under Akhenaton
Cousteau is up sorry Tanner Harvey Denis
Reichle Sam super super nanny opposite
uncommitted I'm dr. Nicholas II rock my
poster here Kutcher are you
[Music]
to Sharma Graham Lotz Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mamasan Luger TTR Turin Bakuman
Donington kini our portal oh my lord
prince suta soma please forgive my
transgression but why cap is not out of
the palace at night
it's time you ascended the throne as
regarded to nurse murder woman yes for
tuning would ya
chuckling you know towel on Tito monarch
artists you chart oh no no don't come
a-knockin Atrato our open unity oh sorry
sorry
I'm Lara Condren barato Jose Marti
talent you see that you are not
interested in worldly approach much less
in marrying the princess Chandra WA and
becoming he you is only to meditate in
the solitude you are drawn only to
spiritual methods but my lord you rule
you have no business meditating in the
forest you must become a democracy
democracy Oh mint incarnate England are
pondered righto yogi Alec Oh Matt McCain
Kananga co-angler Akane carnally oh
goodness paragraph lama conocido como
marine kazoo not to uncover underling
chuckling aha you say he you were born
in the court but you decide to meditate
not rule you said that if you stay in
the court and marry you will never a
spiritual awareness being distracted by
worldly things but excuse me my lord if
we want to study it well things you can
do this in the court there is no reason
to go to the forest
you pick a desaturate Italian man
Margaux Hikari
Sakana me boyo Pocoyo Marcus Danang can
lock on intermetallic own way you say
you must go to the forest to meditate
okay my lord I will follow you but wait
a moment I will want to bring my son
Murdock as his heart an accident is
living with Africa okay okay okay okay
I will follow you to the forest y ahora
tu dois goon t literally runs a candy
poker unit recording we are tuning summa
kalla father to market at the Naga
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yummy what here our goal a car come over
yell oh we will go to year now right
let's move
[Music]
why must we follow our master Biff into
the forest because we must we are
servants after long at home at this time
we would be chillaxing by the pool with
the peel but here nothing but fasting
and meditating do not think about the
earth there we are in the forest now we
must appreciate our truffle and the
beauty of the forest he was strange the
forest with you with he would tell Fred
how old are you now I don't know about
40 and still single you should you take
care of yourself better and look for a
wife I enjoy following our master it is
a constant adventure this forest is
enough to make me happy meditating in
the forest give me a break
only a lazy bum like you would enjoy it
this you never liked working well we are
better a following of a master for now
okay okay
but I would still like Mochaccino right
about now but there is no Starbucks I
will this just imagine one in my
meditation but they can
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one little Swan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one part about working on some under me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
zero-zero song super solo Jacques Attali
market she grew to market a choleric
reckonin yoga Daniel okay okay my lord
hahaha let us be dinner who meditation
okay no need to talk sit quietly and
meditate okay okay so meditation is just
sitting with you is roots right you must
clear your mind do not think of anything
just concentrate on your breath him and
how okay I can note that every time I
close my eyes all I see is girls pretty
girls passing by
do not worry just let the stoats pass
okay how can i they are really cute the
more I try not to think about them the
cuter [ __ ] Cikini ones chubby ones
blowing hair brown hair okay okay just
end with them and be quiet
Thanks but look the beautiful princess
Chandra party our Lord fiancée is coming
she will surely distract our Lord in his
meditation
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh or no war no gravity no mae-mae Mila
wonky corn Harlan on in Iran and
Montrose Loretta Utah need not listen
[Music]
[Music]
we holly has given a powerful mantra to
suta soma
as a reward for his strength in
meditation with this mantra he can
remove all obstacles in his path of
enlightenment but she did not give me a
month after all my meditation I would
like a mantra that would help me look
younger you go see the suitors somewhere
and TM karna one perhaps not an Inca
track Italian wait
o villain are to pamper concealed upon
Aikido
[Music]
your song is
[Music]
Sontaran a canonical suit Asuma you
desire to meditate but truly you must
marry and become king it is your karma
but I must study much more I do not yet
know myself go to to the Marx Mitra he
will help good advice for you young man
Karina quad and party super
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm o suta so my I have been waiting for
you my name before becoming a monk was
Jaya singing I am your grandfather I
have heard much about you and want to
study with you don't think of studying
with me we shall simply share our
experience but there is something you
must know you will marry the princess
generality but why I have no toast of
merit only of meditation you cannot deny
your karma in your previous incarnation
you was also a wife the tantric
teachings show us that we do not need to
become a monk to find our separate
quality you can live in the world and
reach enlightenment if you live
intentionally and with compassion but
there is something you must do first you
must guide subtler muscle back to his
daughter who else automa
listen and I will tell you see you all
monk are no zero
what I want summe truly are to to Mari -
I can really love you
she loose one suit
[Music]
[Applause]
Sugiyama was us student in the previous
life was killed in getting missile was a
fit in too and when the reincarnated
entered into the body of the child
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he have become evil engineers they are
destroying the forest they have
forgotten
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
with Sutil Amada he was at us all my
student in previous life I yes I'll do
educated in the laws of Dharma in the
previous life in this lab sutiramisu has
split in two like full timers but his
sunless now spit into the bodies of the
ogre Gajuwaka in the dragon Agha well
just like Hawk tracks from hello una mas
de somos and even entire monkey 1 Hunan
cherry to warn Enrico cannoneer series
on quad Jaguar true rock Sasaki
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh let's sing a song okay
what time is very Swift melodies and
very skillfully but enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm happy being the surface of the
cudgel etre he is so powerful no one is
ripped enough to face him powerful I am
also powerful and strong very strong
very powerful powerful and strong you
have fruit of this oh I really do not
like this why do I have to become the
cellphone of an ogre you should feel
lucky good an all girl's life is the
best rules the ethics total freedom you
know no ogres are immoral you know
humans have too many rules that is the
problem
Oh girls Abner rules and that fits me
just fine the lip stress-free healthy no
limits on what they can eat and always
eats at Mass at daylight that which new
rules is the life of a new version oh I
do not care of if like an animal or
humans or freedom is the most important
things marry as many time as you want
okay it is the freedom that keep the
augur happy and healthy only humans with
all the rules and regulation gets
with the concern okay so troop Corona
if retention and depletion go to the
hospital you see any organs now it is
impossible to talk to you you do not
know right from wrong up from down
you only think of yourself ah it is
humans that only think of themselves
humans are the most arrogant beings they
do not take care of it at the day are
greedy they should it added the Makua no
ogre is a permit a nuclear bomb you know
me they were up to but humans can
correct their mistakes they can help
it's harder you know adapt talking's no
more debating we are agree to disagree
oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
never enter now we are not to do one go
[Laughter]
relax relax okay we met okay okay just
let's we go to the forest okay
find some food held an emergency snow in
the forest okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
what is that sound all the animals are
running out of the forest what is
scaring them away
[Applause]
[Music]
this must be the soma you must face him
young man I know I owe you nothing
partner
hey are you going hurry up no but your
Honda should have got you walked through
long McConnachie do what amar
concurrency loo your
[Music]
stop killing this animal okay I killed
them because I'm hammered
they are my foot okay but you kill more
than you eat and destroy the balance of
nature
yeah don't talk too much what I will
give you special perfume of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we took charge Oh Sarge and alimony nah
can can cannot I am I will kill you
okay okay but I won't use my making
power you know let's wait for your
caboose wah wah oh that is my magic
weapon
you see Swampert Swampert Swampert East
Rome fire okay
[Music]
not just wrong enough but I will give
you also K major also I will give you
special okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I will keep your very special refunds
match equipment okay what this corner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait ups octi supermarket Romania Turkey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wasn't aware take a mop on cross or
American on a boat and cuddle with me
and in Monaco oh my lord excuse me
I now know your true identity please
accept me as your disciple young man can
opener
we at America on top of Brad Cooper you
wanna do
[Music]
Jellico would this is a real smooth
our bosses change side what should we do
let us follow i was our boss and try to
live with the humans now I have an
allergy to human you know knock oh no do
not system is different he is wise and
powerful he has sold me my Dharma
[Music]
[Music]
one of us or she would not good please
forgive me please accept me as your
disciple
eunbong fairness policy of our immediate
Oh almost our secrets immunity one 100
Impala see
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for inviting us to New Haven